[Music]
Facebook that's the big story this yeah
you know stock you know IPO not so great
yeah but Facebook making a lot of
investors rich yeah it was reported I
don't if you heard this that u2 singer
Bono may have made over a billion
dollars from Facebook going public you
know that Bono yeah he spokesman for you
to said the band is still going to tour
but only because the drummer invested
heavily in MySpace he's lost he's the
saddest drummer in the world it goes
really slowly for every song yet anyone
see the movie Battleship I thought so
you can learn a lot doing a show like
this the answer would be no the movie
Battleship based on the board game
battleship had a tough first week at the
box office not doing well at all yet
went so poorly the studio has already
suspended production on the new movie
Yahtzee the reckoning
huyn I get a sense you'd rather see
Yahtzee The Reckoning or shoots and lead
Candyland this time he wins what no this
time it's not so sweet yeah like that it
was horrible better than Oh dare you
talk about mine was better
I'm sorry you had to see this was
horrible Al Gore did here but Al Gore Al
Gore has a new girlfriend who is what
was that we're gonna cut to Andy
entering the jokes now I'm the switch
here this folks why did the chicken
cross the road
tell ya it's good know Al Gore has a new
girlfriend
who is very very devoted apparently to
environmental issues yeah not nice yeah
that's nice yeah Gore says his
girlfriend's been fighting deforestation
by creating new wood that's the way this
show is gonna be all night we get a
little dirty on Thursdays never on
Mondays no you don't they wouldn't
probably at that early in the we had
they wouldn't put up with it yeah that's
when that's when children come to the
show speaking of children I couldn't
believe this a new study shows current
members of Congress speak at a tenth
grade level that's true
they speak at a tenth grade level when
reached for comment House Majority
Leader Eric Cantor said nah
yeah yes yes he he spoke at the tenth
grade
a new report just came out and it claims
that good cholesterol may not be as
beneficial as previously thought yeah
this is really bad news for Domino's new
good cholesterol stuffed pizza that's
all I wanted I wanted one shot of an T I
wanted I wanted to make him an
accomplice in that joke I'm sorry I'd
stepped out for a minute she should just
be gone
sometimes you detect you let me cut you
you're out smoking a cigarette outside
the the mint I'm sorry what was that
[Applause]
the the Miss Universe pageant was last
weekend and the transgender Miss Canada
did not win apparently judges were not
impressed by her talent having an Adam's
apple
it's like look check it out a new
smartphone app has been designed to let
people know when they are too drunk to
drive yeah here's how it works your
phone calls a cab as soon as you tell it
I Love You Man
DC Comics we got any comic book fans
here
they're wearing their pajamas well DC
Comics is reporting that one of their
prominent characters will soon come out
as gay yeah and if that goes well
they're going to change the characters
The Watchmen to the guys who really love
to watch men
[Music]
you